y, por último, mi capacidad de hablar.
Mientras estaba en el hospital,
quería ir a casa desesperadamente.
Le dije a mi madre: "¿Cuándo casa?"
Esas fueron las últimas palabras que dije con mi propia voz.
Con el tiempo fallé en todas las pruebas de conciencia mental.
Les dijeron a mis padres que ya no estaba ahí.
Era un vegetal, con la inteligencia de un bebé de 3 meses.
Les dijeron que me llevaran a casa y trataran de mantenerme cómodo
hasta que muriera.
Mis padres, de hecho la vida de toda mi familia,
se consumió por cuidar de mí lo mejor que pudieron.
Sus amigos se alejaron.
Un año se convirtió en dos,
dos se volvieron tres.
Parecía que la persona que una vez fui empezaba a desaparecer.
Quitaron mis Legos y mis circuitos electrónicos que había amado de niño.
Me pasaron de mi habitación a otra más práctica.
Me había convertido en un fantasma,
un recuerdo de un muchacho al que la gente una vez conoció y amó.
Mientras tanto, mi mente comenzó a ensamblarse a sí misma de nuevo.
Poco a poco, mi conciencia empezó a regresar.
Pero nadie se dio cuenta de que había vuelto a la vida.
Estaba al tanto de todo,
como cualquier persona normal.
Podía ver y entender todo,
pero no podía encontrar una manera de que alguien lo supiera.
Mi personalidad estaba sepultada dentro de un cuerpo aparentemente silencioso,
una mente vibrante oculta dentro de una crisálida.
La cruda realidad me golpeó al imaginar que iba a pasar
el resto de mi vida encerrado en mí mismo,
totalmente solo.
Estaba atrapado con mis pensamientos como única compañía.
Nunca me rescatarían.
Nadie podría demostrarme ternura.
Nunca podría hablar con un amigo.
Nadie podría amarme.
No tenía sueños, ni esperanza, ni nada que esperar.
Bueno, nada agradable.
Vivía con miedo,
y, para decirlo sin rodeos,
esperaba la muerte para finalmente liberarme,
esperaba morir solo un hogar de cuidado.
No sé si es realmente posible expresar con palabras
qué es no poder comunicarse.
Tu personalidad parece desvanecerse en una densa niebla,
todas tus emociones y deseos se contraen, se sofocan y se silencian.
Para mí, lo peor era la sensación de total impotencia.
Simplemente existía.
Es un lugar muy oscuro para encontrarse
porque en cierto sentido, uno ha desaparecido.
Otras personas controlaban todos los aspectos de mi vida.
Decidían qué comía y cuándo.
Si habría de estar acostado o en mi silla de ruedas.
A menudo me pasaba los días frente al televisor
viendo repeticiones de Barney.
Creo que como Barney es muy feliz y alegre,
y yo definitivamente no,
eso lo hizo mucho peor.
Era completamente impotente para cambiar nada en mi vida
o la percepción de la gente de mí.
Era un observador silencioso e invisible de cómo se comportaban las personas
cuando pensaban que nadie estaba mirando.
Por desgracia, no era solo un observador.
Sin manera de comunicarme, me convertí en la víctima perfecta:
un objeto indefenso, aparentemente desprovisto de sentimientos
que las personas usaban para sacar sus deseos más oscuros.
Durante más de 10 años, las personas que me cuidaban
abusaron de mí física, verbal y sexualmente.
A pesar de lo que pensaban, yo sentía.
La primera vez que sucedió,
me quedé muy sorprendido y lleno de incredulidad.
¿Cómo pudieron hacerme esto?
Estaba confundido.
¿Qué había hecho para merecer esto?
Una parte de mí quería llorar y otra parte quería luchar.
Dolor, tristeza e ira corrían a través de mí.
Me sentía inútil.
No había nadie que me consolara.
Pero mis padres no sabían lo que estaba sucediendo.
Vivía con terror, sabiendo que sucedería una y otra vez.
Nunca sabía cuándo.
Todo lo que sabía era que nunca volvería a ser el mismo.
Recuerdo que una vez escuchando a Whitney Houston cantar:
"No importa lo que me quiten, no me pueden quitar mi dignidad",
me dije a mí mismo: "¿quieres apostar?"
Tal vez mis padres pudieran haberlo descubierto y me habrían ayudado.
Pero los años de cuidado constante,
tener que despertarse cada 2 horas para darme vuelta,
combinado con el duelo por la pérdida de su hijo,
habían hecho mella en mi madre y mi padre.
Presenciando una acalorada discusión entre mis padres,
en un momento de desesperación,
mi madre se volvió hacia mí y me dijo que debería morir.
Me quedé conmocionado, pero mientras pensaba en lo que había dicho,
estaba lleno de una enorme compasión y amor por mi madre,
pero no podía hacer nada al respecto.
Hubo muchos momentos en los que me di por vencido,
hundiéndome en un abismo oscuro.
Recuerdo un momento particularmente bajo.
Mi padre me dejó solo en el coche
mientras iba rápidamente a comprar algo en la tienda.
Un extraño pasó por delante,
me miró y sonrió.
Nunca sabré por qué, pero ese simple acto,
ese momento fugaz de conexión humana,
transformó cómo me sentía,
dándome ganas de seguir adelante.
Mi existencia era torturada por la monotonía,
una realidad que a menudo era demasiado difícil de soportar.
A solas con mis pensamientos, construí fantasías intrincadas
sobre hormigas que corrían por el suelo.
Me enseñé a leer la hora notando dónde estaban las sombras.
Mientras aprendía cómo las sombras se movían a lo largo del día,
comprendí cuánto tiempo pasaría antes de que me recogieran y me llevaran a casa.
Ver a mi padre caminar a través de la puerta para recogerme
era el mejor momento del día.
Mi mente se convirtió en una herramienta que podía usar
para ya sea cerrarme y evadirme de mi realidad
o para llenar un espacio gigantesco con fantasías.
Esperaba que mi realidad cambiara
y alguien pudiera ver que había vuelto a la vida.
Pero me habían desvanecido como un castillo de arena
construido demasiado cerca de las olas,
y en mi lugar estaba la persona que esperaban que fuera.
Para algunos era Martin, una cáscara vacía, un vegetal,
merecedor de palabras duras, rechazo e incluso abuso.
Para otros, era el desgraciado chico con daño cerebral
que había crecido hasta convertirse en un hombre.
Alguien por quién preocuparse y cuidar.
Para bien o para mal, era un lienzo en blanco
sobre el que se proyectaron diferentes versiones de mí mismo.
Se necesitó de alguien nuevo para verme de una manera diferente.
Una aromaterapista comenzó a venir a la casa a cuidarme una vez a la semana.
Ya sea por intuición o atención a los detalles
que los demás no podían ver,
se convenció de que podía entender lo que decían.
Instó a mis padres a que me vieran expertos
en la comunicación aumentativa y alternativa.
Y en un año,
estaba empezando a usar un programa de computadora para comunicarme.
Era emocionante, pero a veces frustrante.
Tenía tantas palabras en mi mente,
que no podía esperar para poder compartirlas.
A veces, me diría cosas a mí mismo, simplemente porque podía.
En mí mismo, tenía un público listo,
y creí que al expresar mis pensamientos y deseos,
los demás también escucharían.
Pero cuando comencé a comunicarme más,
me di cuenta de que en realidad era solo el comienzo
de crear una voz nueva para mí.
Me sumergí en un mundo que no sabía muy bien cómo funciona.
Dejé de ir al hogar de cuidado
y logré conseguir mi primer trabajo haciendo fotocopias.
Tan simple como esto puede sonar, fue increíble.
Mi nuevo mundo era muy emocionante
pero a menudo bastante abrumador y aterrador.
Era como un hombre-niño,
y liberador como a menudo era,
luché.
También aprendí que muchos de quienes conocía de mucho tiempo
les era imposible abandonar la idea del Martin que tenían en sus cabezas.
Mientras que aquellos que apenas acababa de conocer
luchaban para ver más allá de un hombre silencioso en una silla de ruedas.
Me di cuenta de que algunas personas solo me escucharían
si lo que dijera era acorde a lo que esperaban.
De lo contrario, lo ignorarían
y harían lo que consideraban lo mejor.
Descubrí que la verdadera comunicación
es algo más que simplemente transmitir físicamente un mensaje.
Se trata de hacer que el mensaje sea escuchado y respetado.
Aún así, las cosas iban bien.
Mi cuerpo estaba poniéndose lentamente más fuerte.
Tenía un trabajo en informática que me encantaba,
e incluso tenía a Kojak, el perro con el que había estado soñando durante años.
Sin embargo, deseaba compartir mi vida con alguien.
Recuerdo mirar por la ventana cuando mi padre me llevaba de regreso del trabajo
y pensar que tengo tanto amor dentro de mí y nadie a quién darlo.
Cuando ya me había resignado a estar solo el resto de mi vida,
conocí a Joan.
No solo es lo mejor que me ha pasado,
sino que Joan me ayudó a desafiar mis propias ideas falsas sobre mí.
Joan dijo que era a través de mis palabras que se enamoró de mí.
Sin embargo, después de todo lo que he pasado,
aún no podía quitarme la creencia
de que nadie realmente podía ver más allá de mi discapacidad
y aceptarme por lo que soy.
También me costó comprender que era un hombre.
La primera vez que alguien se refirió a mí como un hombre,
me detuve en seco.
Pensaba en mirar alrededor y preguntar: "¿Quién, yo?"
Todo eso cambió con Joan.
Tenemos una conexión increíble
y he aprendido lo importante que es la comunicación abierta y honesta.
Me sentí seguro y me dio la confianza para decir realmente lo que pensaba.
Empecé a sentir de nuevo todo, un hombre digno de amor.
Empecé a remodelar mi destino.
Hablé un poco más en el trabajo.
Afirmé mi necesidad de independencia con las personas que me rodean.
Con un medio de comunicación cambió todo.
Usé el poder de la palabra y de la voluntad para desafiar los prejuicios
de los que me rodean y los que tenía de mí mismo.
La comunicación es lo que nos hace humanos,
lo que permite conectarnos a un nivel más profundo
con los que nos rodean,
contar nuestras propias historias,
expresar deseos, necesidades y deseos,
o escuchar las de los demás al realmente escuchar.
Así es como el mundo sabe quiénes somos.
Así que ¿quiénes somos nosotros sin ella?
La verdadera comunicación aumenta la comprensión
y crea un mundo más solidario y compasivo.
Una vez, me percibían como un objeto inanimado,
el fantasma sin mente de un niño en una silla de ruedas.
Hoy, soy mucho más.
Un marido, un hijo, un amigo,
un hermano, un empresario, un graduado con honores,
un fotógrafo amateur.
Es mi capacidad de comunicar la que me ha dado todo esto.
Se nos dice que las acciones hablan más que las palabras.
Pero me pregunto,
¿de verdad?
Nuestras palabras, como sea que las comuniquemos
son muy poderosas.
Si decimos las palabras con nuestras propias voces,
las escribimos con nuestros ojos,
o las comunicamos no verbalmente a alguien que las diga por nosotros,
las palabras se encuentran entre nuestras herramientas más poderosas.
He venido a Uds. a través de una terrible oscuridad,
arrebatado de ella por almas solidarias
y por el lenguaje mismo.
El acto de que me escuchen hoy lleva más lejos hacia la luz.
Estamos brillando aquí juntos.
Si hay un obstáculo difícil en mi forma de comunicación,
es que a veces me dan ganas de gritar
y otras veces simplemente susurrar una palabra de amor o gratitud.
Todo suena igual.
Pero, por favor,
imaginen esta próxima palabra tan cálidamente como puedan:
Gracias.
(Aplausos)